how to decrease cancer that may have been fueled in the past month by the
glutamine in the protein powder so it's pretty hard to say that oh okay I was
eating poorly this past month or something could that have made my cancer grow
really crazy there's too many factors to like point the blame at one
thing ever so I'd be careful not to do that first of all so let's say you know let
say you a person's cancer grew really quick you know in the last 60 days and they
go I've been way off my diet that's really it well you can't say that you just
don't know what factors are involved with growth it's not always diet it's not
always you know why it was eating glutamine that's the reason so don't get me
wrong or don't just because I said you should be eating glutamine if you have
cancer doesn't mean that it's good to grow like crazy for a person that has
cancer that has cancer it's not that is necessarily good to be the cause of the
factor of that so just you can't take that dogmatic and it's and exact there's
it there's not a perfect scenario there so don't beat yourself up about that I'm
just saying this we got to use wisdom in all our decision-making processes and
if I have a cancer I'm not going to be taking an exogenous glutamine powder
you know that could be a fuel source right I'm just going to be wise it's just
like okay if I have a cancer that's growing I need to clean up my diet but to be
honest I have patients that some of you might be in this category I don't know
but I have I've had patients over the years that have come to me and say hey I'll do
the right thing I'll take a few supplements but I ain't changing my diet one I
just want to let you know that typically it's a guy and it's like good assakes
they got better so it's like so is diet important yeah I think diet support is
it you know always important no so it just just keep that in mind you know if you do
have cancer growth over a period of time how could I you do everything you know
what to do to put the brakes on it that's the answer to that question don't
start you know second guessing yourself and beating yourself up and blaming
yourself and you know you know blame me to practitioner that put you on
something or I just think there's not health in that so okay it is what it is
I'm gonna learn something new and when you learn something new you try to apply
that thing new you don't go back in time and and cause guilt and shame or
anything else that could be doing so just make sure you're not doing that